so i'm starting us out today with a
historical mystery
in 1957 there were two young women both
in their 20s
both living in the same city both
members of the same political group
that year both decided to commit violent
attacks
one girl took a gun and approached a
soldier at a checkpoint
the other girl took a bomb and went to a
crowded cafe
but here's the thing one of those girls
followed through with the attack but the
other
turned back so what made the difference
i'm a behavioral historian and i study
aggression
moral cognition and decision making
in social movements that's a mouthful
so the translation of that is i study
the moment
an individual decides to pull the
trigger
the day-to-day decisions that led up to
that moment
and the stories that they tell
themselves about
why that behavior is justified
now this topic it's not just scholarly
for me
it's actually a bit personal i
grew up in kootenay county idaho and
this is very
important this is not the part of
idaho with potatoes we have
no potatoes and if you ask me about
potatoes i will find you
this part of idaho is known for mountain
lakes
horseback riding skiing
unfortunately starting in the 1980s
it also became known as the worldwide
headquarters
for the aryan nations every year
members of the local neo-nazi compound
would turn out and march through our
town
and every year members of our town would
turn out and protest them
now in 2001 i graduated from high school
and i went to college in new york city
i arrived in august 2001
as many of you probably are aware three
weeks
later the twin towers went down
now i was shocked
i was incredibly angry
i wanted to do something but the only
thing that i could think of doing at
that time
was to study arabic
i will admit i was that girl in class
that
wanted to know why they hate us
i started studying arabic for very wrong
reasons
but something unexpected happened and i
got a scholarship to go
study in israel so the idaho girl went
to the middle east
and while i was there i met
palestinian muslims palestinian
christians
israeli settlers israeli peace activists
and what i learned is that every act
has an ecology it has a context now
since then
i have gone around the world i have
studied uh violent movements i have
worked with ngos
and ex-combatants in iraq syria the
vietnam the balkans cuba
i earned my phd in history and now what
i do is i
go to different archives and i dig
through documents
looking for police confessions
court cases diaries manifestos of
individuals involved in violent attacks
now you gather all these documents
what do they tell you our brains love
causal mysteries it turns out so any
time we see an
attack on the news we tend to ask one
question
why why did it happen well i can tell
you
i've read thousands of manifestos and
what you find out is that they are
actually imitative
they imitate the political movement that
they're drawing from
so they actually don't tell us a lot
about decision making
in that particular case so we have to
teach ourselves to
ask a totally different question instead
of why
we have to ask how how did individuals
produce these attacks
and how did their decision-making
ecology contribute to violent behavior
there's a couple of things i've learned
from asking this kind of question
the most important thing is that
political violence is not
culturally endemic we create it and
whether we realize it or not our
day-to-day habits
contribute to the creation of violence
in our environment so here's a couple of
habits
that i've learned contribute to violence
one of the first things that attackers
did
when preparing themselves for a violent
event
was they enclosed themselves in an
information bubble
we've heard of fake news yeah well
this shocked me every group that i
studied had some kind of a fake news
slogan
french communists called it the putrid
press
french ultra nationalists called it the
sellout press
and the treasonous press islamist in
egypt called it the
depraved news and egyptian communists
called it
fake news so why do groups spend all
this time
trying to make these information bubbles
the answer is actually
really simple we make decisions based on
the information we trust
yeah so if we trust bad
information we're gonna make bad
decisions
another interesting habit that
individuals used
when they wanted to produce a violent
attack was that they looked at their
victim
not as an individual but just as a
member of an opposing team
now this gets really weird there's some
fun brain science behind
why that kind of thinking is effective
say
i divide all of you guys into two teams
blue team
red team and then i ask you to compete
in a game against each other well the
funny thing is within
milliseconds you will actually start
experiencing
pleasure pleasure when something
bad happens to members of the other team
the funny thing about that is if i ask
one of you blue team members
to go and join the red team your brain
recalibrates
and within milliseconds you will now
start experiencing pleasure
when bad things happen to members of
your old team
this this is a really good example of
why us them thinking is so dangerous
in our political environment another
habit that attackers used to kind of
rev themselves up for an attack was they
focused on differences
in other words they looked at their
victims and they thought
i share nothing in common with that
person they're totally different than me
again this might sound like a really
simple concept but there's some
fascinating
science behind why this works
say i show you guys videos
of different colored hands and sharp
pins
being driven into these different
colored hands okay
if you're white the chances are
you will experience the most sympathetic
activation
or the most pain when you see a pin
going into the white hand
if you are latin american arab black
you will probably experience the most
sympathetic activation
watching a pin going into the hand that
looks most like yours
the good news is that's not biologically
fixed
that is learned behavior which means
the more we spend time with other ethnic
communities and the more we see them as
similar to us and part of our team
the more we feel their pain the last
habit that i'm going to talk about
is when attackers prepared themselves to
go out and do one of these events
they focused on certain emotional cues
for months
they geared themselves up by focusing on
anger cues
for instance i bring this up because
it's really popular right now if you
read blogs or the news
you see talk of two concepts from
laboratory science uh
mig doula hijacking and emotional
hijacking
now amygdala hijacking it's the concept
that i
show you a cue say a gun and your
brain reacts with an automatic threat
response
to that cue emotional hijacking it's a
very similar concept it's the idea that
i
show you an anger cue for instance
and your brain will react with an
automatic anger response to that cue
i think women usually get this more than
men
that kind of a hijacking narrative grabs
our attention
just the word hijacking grabs our
attention
the thing is most of the time that's not
really
how cues work in real life
if you study history what you find is
that we are bombarded with
hundreds of thousands of cues every day
and so what we do is we learn to filter
we ignore some cues
we pay attention to other cues for
political violence this becomes
really important because what it meant
is that attackers
usually didn't just see an
anger cue and suddenly snap
instead politicians
social activists spent weeks
months years flooding the environment
with anger cues for instance
and attackers they paid attention to
those cues
they trusted those cues they focused on
them
they even memorized those cues all of
this
just really goes to show how important
it is
to study history it's one thing to see
how cues operate in a laboratory setting
and those laboratory experiments are
incredibly important they give us a lot
of new data
about how our bodies work
but it's also very important to see how
those cues operate in real life
so what does all this tell us about
political violence
political violence is not culturally
endemic
it is not an automatic predetermined
response to environmental stimuli
we produce it our everyday habits
produce it
let's go back actually to those two
women that i mentioned at the start the
first woman had been paying attention to
those outrage campaigns
so she took a gun and approached a
soldier at a checkpoint
but in that moment something really
interesting happened
she looked at that soldier and she
thought to herself
he he's the same age as me
he looks like me
and she put down the gun and she walked
away
just from that little bit of similarity
the second girl had a totally different
outcome
she also listened to the outrage
campaigns but she surrounded herself
with individuals who were supportive of
violence with peers
who supported her violence she
enclosed herself in an information
bubble
she focused on certain emotional cues
for months
she taught herself to bypass certain
cultural inhibitions against violence
she practiced her plan she taught
herself
new habits and when the time came she
took
her bomb to the cafe and she followed
through with that attack
this was not impulse
this was learning
polarization in our society is not
impulse it's learning
every day we are teaching ourselves the
news
we click on the emotions that we focus
on the thoughts
that we entertain about the red team or
the blue team
all of this contributes to learning
whether we realize it or not
the good news is that while the
individuals i
study already made their decisions
we can still change our trajectory
we might never make the decisions that
they made
but we can stop contributing to violent
ecologies
we can get out of whatever news bubble
we're in
we can be more mindful about the
emotional cues that we focus on the
outrage bait that we click on but most
importantly we can
stop seeing each other as just members
of the red team
or the blue team because whether we
are christian muslim jewish
atheists democrat republican
we're human we're human beings
and we often share really similar habits
we have differences those differences
are beautiful
and those differences are very important
but our
future depends on us
being able to find common ground with
the other side
and that's why it is so so important
for us to retrain our brains and stop
contributing to violent ecologies
thank you
you